élu dès le premier tour en 2014 gilles
platret repart en campagne
sourire et projets en bandoulière sur le
marché de l'hôtel de ville à ses côtés
comme il ya six ans sébastien martin le
président de la communauté
d'agglomération à duo qui défend son
bilan
on est fier de ce qu'on a fait en six
ans on l'a fait du boulot
peut-être peut-on juger qu'on a bien
fait ou mal fait mais en tout cas on
n'est pas resté les deux pieds dans le
même sabot
on a agi donc si sur cette base là on
peut au moins nous faire confiance en
disant avec qui on sait où on va ils
sont capables d'agir mais ça ne vaut que
si le projet est intéressant c'est le
projet qu'on défend ce moment et à ceux
qui reprochent au vice président
national des républicains de ne pas
avoir été assez présent pour ses
administrés
gilles platret répond on a lancé il ya
six ans c'est un engagement de campagne
ce qu'on appelle le maire en direct le
fait que les chalonnais un jour par
semaine puisse venir me voir sans rendez
vous à l'hôtel de ville
j'ai reçu plus de 2000 chalonnais et ça
c'est à l'hôtel de ville je ne compte
pas les milieux chalonnais qui ont été
vus sur le terrain dans sa permanence
entouré d'une bonne partie de ses
colistiers
nathalie leblanc est prête à faire front
la conseillère municipale d'opposition
espère clairement faire rebasculer la
ville à gauche même si elle se défend de
vouloir réécrire l'histoire
j'ai absolument pas dans un esprit de
revanche ans sont en revanche sûr que je
regarde c'est ce qui s'est passé mais de
2014 à 2020 mais certainement pas en
2014 pour cette ancienne adjointe de
christophe sirugue des quartiers entiers
de chalon sur saône ont été abandonnés
par l'équipe sortante
il y avait un vaste programme de
rénovation urbaine sur ce quartier des
prés saint jean qui a été annulée par
l'actuelle municipalité et les
rénovations ont été portées que les
dernières quinze d'affaires porté que
par le bailleur social
donc il ya eu encore des rénovations de
fait pas tout et puis vous êtes promenés
avec moi dans le quartier où il ya des
trous plein d'eau des eaux rien et c'est
donc tout ce qui est le cadre de vie n'a
absolument pas été touché durant cette
cette mandature
un duel gauche droite à l'ancienne sur
les rives de la saône
le scénario est dépassée pour alain
rousselot payet l'ancien maire de
châtenoy en bresse conseillers
communautaires investi par la république
en marche c'est qu'il n'aura pas la
tâche facile mais il assume
nous avons souhaité en tout cas garder
notre étiquette de la république en
marche parce que nous sommes fidèles à
nos convictions
elle nous voulons pas nous cacher si
vous voulez derrière des listes sans
étiquette ou on sait que chacun est
souvent d'ailleurs les candidats cumule
déjà des fonctions électives que ce soit
départementales régionales mais qui sont
bien qu'ils sont bien dus à des partis
politiques
la référence assumée du candidat la rems
et dominique perben qui a dirigé la
ville de 1983 à 2002 il a fait des
choses en son temps qui ne sont pas
forcément qu'ils soient pas forcément
les mêmes aujourd'hui faut adapter les
choses mais en tout cas la ligne la
vision la politique était la bonne et
c'est ce que je veux incarner demain sur
cette ville de chalon sur saône dans la
zone sonné or le candidat du
rassemblement national franck diop jeune
chef d'entreprise de 32 ans a lui aussi
son exemple à suivre
roger lagrange le maire socialiste de la
cité de niepce de 1965 à 1983
depuis roger lagrange encore une fois
qu'est ce qui était fait
quels ont été les politiques ont été les
plus sains et les plus intéressantes et
où l entreprise qui a pris le qui a pris
le pli de kodak faire revenir davantage
d'emplois sur l'ancien site du géant de
la photo faire émerger des talents de la
diversité dans les quartiers le candidat
du r n 1 un discours qui détonne et peut
étonner dans son propre camp qui avait
rassemblé plus de 10 % des voix en 2014
on a la chance d'avoir un vrai socle
lorsque les gens sont fidèles nous ne
sommes pas comme certains partis qui
batifole entre eux les gens leurs skis
sont fn ou est reine
il y reste n'a pas parce que c'est des
raciste notoire en quoi c'est parce que
c'est des gens qui ont peut-être envie
de de réellement agir et le seul pas le
seul seule partie faussée il faut se le
dire comme totalement changé aujourd'hui
c'est le cer n quelle place pour le
rassemblement national à chalon c'est
l'une des questions de ces municipales
où les électeurs n'ont pas eu autant de
choix au premier tour depuis longtemps
l'autre inconnue leur mobilisation
en 2014 le taux de participation
s'élevait à 56,2 %